que les gens se demandent les gens se
posent des questions les gens se disent
où en est il
on a l'impression que vous êtes attiré
par cerise de groupama
et pourtant de votre côté
attiré par la banane 2
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
élèves et non avec des mots simples dont
le groupe rend intelligible et sans
vulgarité à la réponse que dave avait
fait fait moureu ni des hommes ni des
femmes je suis amoureux de l'amour
kelly est une rencontre ah oui et
j'avoue que j'aime bien être avec elle
on avait bon enfant on s'ennuie jamais
et yahia qu'il ya quelque chose qui
passe voilà est de l'ordre du surnaturel
alors ce qu'elle soit naturelle et
patrick vous qu'est ce qu'il ya je suis
en manque d'arguments là mais quand on
s'aime beaucoup est-ce que vous avez
tout fait ce film j'ai adoré mais avec
mathieu on s'aime beaucoup prêtent vous
pourriez sortir avec matthew n'ont
infléchi une réponse a beaucoup changé
l'émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non affectant la tâche s'est pas fait
la question s'est dit non j'ai envie de
vous dire pq m non vraiment il a choisi
une autre rive peut-être que oui
d'accord mais là non ah oui mais
attendez alors je vous dirais vous savez
quand on perd en battant jeudi quand on
part en bateau
aussi on veut partir et on sait pas on
arrive alors je vous le dis mathieu il
est parti sur un délire il faut très
vite changé aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il est dont un mathieu ça
vous arrange un peu mon changement
[Rires]
si vous pouviez être un petit peu sur ce
dossier est un petit peu moins soit
l'être cher donc c'est bon on part sur
sa wii allait battre eh bien voilà
non mais je sauve qui peut se plaindre a
dîné ensemble on s'entend très bien
quand beaucoup quand vous l'amenez star
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai que si vous avez
mangé avec elle prévenait avant votre
banquier ou un truc mais les gens qui
sont beaux et avec qui on s'ennuie pas
et quand on passe un bon moment avec
c'est assez rare que mariana penthouses
la cave où il ya la plante on a beau oui
belle tournée vous donnez-vous et kelly
à l'aller c'est moi merci bien des baux
est demeuré dernier dont est déjà assez
dit vous savez que si vous n'étiez pas
si on n'était pas tous les deux voilà
sur d'autres auspices